what's up esther so my question is what
is your advice for newlyweds who didn't
have a good
model for marriage growing up so my
husband and i recently got married
for me our relationship had the ideal
progression despite
unideal circumstances we were introduced
by a mutual friend and we went to the
same parties we
were purely platonic friends for a
couple of months got
interested in each other not too long
after the friendship began
not to make it weird became official
then got married
admittedly the courtship process was fed
up
from us being the only constant constant
in-person interaction we both had
he's my first and my last boyfriend
you i can tell in your voice you are a
laser of passion is that right
okay you're the center way to put it
you're the center of the torch
right and then the world shut down and
you could see no one
no people in new york city but then you
saw this one
and all right go ahead we actually got
together a few months
before kovitz started so i think i got a
good apocalyp
buddy ah there you go and then man that
laser burned on one dude one time
all the time and he was a great
absorbent of that
of that laser and that thing burned hot
and fast
quick is that right yeah i think it was
survival of the fitness in terms of
relationships in 2020 the fact that we
got married after being together that
intentionally
like we made it i guess i guess that was
a good litmus
test all right so how can i help
um the high wore off is that where we're
at
no it's not that it's actually me just
wanting to make sure that we spend the
rest of our lives together as much as
possible
because a challenge yeah thank you a
challenge i'm experiencing is that we're
an interracial
and an interfaith couple and our mothers
have strongly expressed their
disapproval of us getting into an
interracial
and interfaith relationship throughout
our lives we have a lot of differences
he was born and raised in new york and i
grew up in
asia and i moved to america when i was
an adult and i'm still getting used to
the new york culture and american life
um similarities we have we both don't
have anything to do with our parents
anymore so for me
it's making our marriage feel very
lonely in that sense that we didn't have
a good
model so in both our cases one parent
passed away
due to terminal illness and the other
parent is no longer
in our lives no longer has any bearing
on our lives
in fact i've totally cut out my living
parent because it was so toxic around
them that i actually had to run away
from my physical safety
so yeah my husband and i both grew up in
religious households
in which religion was justified was used
to justify abuse
so personally i have experienced the
whole bang really
the emotional physical um everything
that's actually why i had to run away
from home and it made me
quite frankly hate men the fact that i
got married is really a miracle
you know what the lester it's not a
miracle it was a life raft
and when you walk through all of these
challenges that you just
put out there
a interfaith inner racial
parents have abandoned you you're still
getting used to a new culture
you are a an abuse survivor you are a
religion a religious abuse survivor
you still have some faith he's got no
faith whatever
you guys have you guys have got high
together
you guys got high and you tried to solve
all of your problems with one another
and one another can't
solve each other's problems like that
and that got intense and that got quick
and that got heavy and that got
and now it's getting very very real okay
so here's here's what i want you to
think through okay esther this is a
one of those things like if someone says
hey how do i lose weight you just go die
and exercise
sounds really simple but it's really
hard okay are you ready
yeah all right you
number one have to get some models in
your life
you've got to invest intentionally
in couples who have been married longer
than you that you want to emulate
it'd be great if they were interfaith
it'd be great if they were interracial
because they could understand some of
those complexities that y'all are gonna
have to navigate together
but having a couple of models would be
ideal here's the second thing
you guys have to get some community
you're gonna burn each other up
because the other person cannot handle i
lost my mom because of you i lost my
faith because of you i'm losing part of
my culture because of you i'm losing
part of my
ethnic and racial heritage because of
you that will melt each other
that you're a laser beam and my guess is
he is too
or he's a recipient of a laser and at
some point that just burns
so you got to get other people in your
life whether that's my preference would
be some really close wonderful friends
that you can share life with
and ebb and flow and move with and
here's the last thing
you all have to do really hard work
building
a picture of what tomorrow's going to
look like and
practice living into it here's what i
mean by that
you guys were on fire y'all practice
safety right is he a good friend is he a
good buddy
is he a good romantic partner we're
practicing safety awesome
awesome awesome then you achieved safety
you you said that guy's safe enough i'm
gonna marry
he said she is on fire and i love her
and she's safe enough to marry
now here's what you have to practice
you've got to practice
desire you have to practice doing things
that are going to make you uncomfortable
but he is going to
love and he's going to do vice versa and
when i say uncomfortable i mean
i want to yell and i want to scratch him
i want to punch him in the face i'm not
going to do that i'm going to hug him
he knows that i'm going to he's going to
want to call his mom and he's not gonna
do that because you've asked him not
like
so when i say uncomfortable i don't mean
unsafe and i don't mean violating any of
your
your boundaries i mean you each
each other each of you are gonna wake up
every day saying how can i
practice intimacy practice desire
how can i make sure that kitchen is
spotless how can i make sure
that laundry is done how can i make sure
that lunch is made whatever those little
little tiny tasks are
and that comes from you learn those from
models you learn those from
deep conversations you learn those from
developing a picture
of what tomorrow is going to look like
where do you want to be what's the
what's the marriage model you want to
have we want to have
laughter we want to go dancing we want
to we want to make
decisions together we want to have
children that are going to grow up
safe in a loving life but also know the
the harmful realities of living in new
york as a biracial couple's interfaith
couple
we want kids who can navigate different
faith perspectives but also land
on this one plate we want all those
things and then you just got to reverse
engineer it
that means we have to talk about faith
when we run into cultural differences
we're not going to blow up we're not
going to go to war we're going to sit
down and say
huh in asia we did it like this and he
says well in
new york we did it like this how can we
make this work for both of us
and it's going to take a process of
learning it's going to take a process of
somebody calling saying hey we're in a
bad dance we're in a dance where we
are we've looped back into old patterns
i'm calling it
let's throw the flag let's all back out
right let's go back in and again let's
go back in again and you're going to
practice and practice
and practice and this is something going
to practice forever and there's going to
be seasons when the desire
is rich and he's the hottest guy you it
is going to burn and esther is going to
be back on fire
and there's going to be days that you
are cold as ice and you're going to have
to practice
you have to practice and then he's going
to say something or you're going to do
something and that safety's going to
wear thin you have to practice safety
again
and you're going to this is the dance of
a relationship and i want you to know
that if you do practice it
and you do find good models and you do
have good community and you do take care
of each other
and you take care of yourselves it's all
so worth it
it's also worth it you end up at
whatever day
your day here is done you have no tread
left on the tires you've laughed every
laugh you're going to have you've hugged
every hug you're going to have
you've had every romantic night you're
going to have your kids have had every
celebration and every heartache and
every heartbreak and you've grieved
deeply and deeply deeply and you've
risen from the ash and he's watered that
ash
so that you can rise and vice versa and
vice versa and vice versa
but it starts with a community starts
with a model
and it starts with you and him sitting
down saying where do we want this to go
what is it going to look like
specifically where is the tv going to go
where are we going to live
how are we going to talk to one another
and then we're going to reverse engineer
that and get there
and i love your heart ester
so good so good so good